part c
let y equals f of x be the particular
solution to the differential equation
with the initial condition f of two is
equal to three
does f have a relative minimum a
relative maximum or neither at x equals
2 justify your answer
well to think about whether we have a
relative minimum or a relative maximum
we could see well what's the derivative
at that point if it's 0 then it's a good
candidate that we're dealing with a that
it could be a relative minimum or
maximum if it's not zero then it's
neither and then if it is zero if we
want to figure out relative minimum or
relative maximum we can evaluate the
sign of the second derivative so let's
just think about this so
we want to evaluate
f prime
we want to figure out what f prime
of
f prime of 2
is equal to
so we know that f prime
of x
f prime of x which is the same thing as
d y
d x
is equal to 2 times x minus y
we saw that in the last problem and so f
prime of 2
write it this way f prime of two is
going to be equal to
two times two
minus whatever y is when x is equal to
two well do we know what y is when x
equals to two
sure they tell us right over here
y is equal to f of x so when x is equal
to 2 when x is equal to 2
y is equal to 3. so 2 times 2
minus 3 and so this is going to be equal
to 4 minus 3 is equal to 1. and so
since the derivative at 2 is not 0 this
is not going to be a minimum a relative
minimum or a relative maximum so it
could say
since
f prime
of 2
f prime of 2 does not equal 0
this
we have a
f has
we write it this way f has
neither
minimum
or relative minimum i guess i could say
relative
min
or
relative
max
at
x equals two
all right let's do the next one
find the values of the constants m and b
for which y equals mx plus b
is a solution to the differential
equation
all right this one is interesting so
let's actually let's just write down
everything we know before we even think
that y equals mx plus b could be a
solution to the differential equation so
we know that
we know that d y
over d x is equal to 2 x minus y they
told us that
we also know that the second derivative
the second derivative of y with respect
to x is equal to two minus d y
d x we figure that out in part b of this
problem
and then we could also express this
we saw that we could also write that as
2 minus 2x plus y if you just substitute
if you substitute this in for that
so it's 2 minus 2x plus y so let me
write it that way so this is also equal
to 2 minus 2x
plus y
so that's everything we know before we
even
thought that maybe there's a solution of
y equals mx plus b
so now let's start with y equals mx plus
b so if y is equal to mx plus b
y equals mx plus b so this is equation
of a line then d y
dx is going to be equal to well the
derivative of this with respect to x is
just m derivative of this with respect
to x it's constant it's not going to
change with respect to x it's just a 0.
and that makes sense the rate of change
of y with respect to x is the slope is
the slope of our line
so can we use and this is really all
that we know we could keep actually we
could go even further we could take the
second derivative here the second
derivative of y with respect to x
well that's going to be zero the second
derivative of a of a linear function
well it's going to be zero and we see
that here so this is this is all of the
information that we have we get this
from the previous parts of the problem
and we get this just taking the first
and second derivatives of of y equals mx
plus b
so given this
can we figure out
can we figure out what m and b are
all right so
we could if we said m is equal to 2x
minus y
that doesn't seem
right this one is a tricky one
let's see we know that the second
derivative is going to be equal to zero
we know that this is going to be equal
to zero for this particular
solution and we know d y d x
is equal to m
we know this is m
and so there you have it we have enough
information to solve for m we know that
0 is equal to 2 minus m
so 0 is equal to 2 minus m
and so we can add m to both sides and we
get m is equal
m
is equal to 2.
so that by itself was quite useful
and then what we could say
let's see can we solve this further
well we know that this right over here d
y d x this is m
this is m and it's equal to two
so
we could say that two is equal to 2x
minus y
2 is equal to 2 x
minus y and then let's see if we solve
for y add y to both sides subtract 2
from both sides we get y is equal to 2x
minus 2. and there we have our whole
solution and so you have your m right
over there that is m and then we also
have our b
this one was a tricky one
anytime that you you have to
you know do something like this and it
doesn't just jump out at you and if it
wasn't obvious it didn't jump out at me
at first when i looked at this problem i
said well let me just write down
everything that they told us so they
wrote this before and then we say okay
this is going to be a solution and so
let me see if i can somehow solve so
let's see what i didn't use i didn't use
i didn't use that
i did use this
i
absolutely used that i did use that i
did use that and i did use that so this
was a little bit of a fun little puzzle
where i just wrote down all the
information they gave us and i tried to
figure out based on that whether i could
figure out m
and
m and b
and this is pretty neat this is a
solution 2x minus 2. if we go to our
slope field above it's not it wouldn't
have jumped out at me but if you think
about if you think about some so 2x
minus 2 it's y intercept would be
negative 2 like that let me do this in a
different color
and so the line would look something
would look something like this
the line would look something like this
and you can verify that any one of these
points
at any one of these points the slope
the slope is equal to slope is equal to
two if we're at the point two comma two
well it's going to be two times two
minus two is two
one comma zero two times one minus zero
is two negative 2 comma sorry 0 comma
negative 2 well 0 minus negative 2
that's 2. so you see this is pretty neat
this the slope is changing all around it
but this is this is a linear solution to
that original differential equation that
was that was pretty cool